♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Welcome back.
And thank you for joining us
for another episode
of the Wine Down.
We are joined today
by the incredible Yvonne Orji.
-Hey.
-Oh, hello.
-Was that the DMX voice? Hey.
-No, no.
It's never the DMX voice.
I'm ready.
-You're ready.
-I'm always.
And we are ready
to dig into episode two,
which is "Lowkey Distant."
ALL: Oof. (LAUGHING)
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
-So Molly met Condola...
-Uh-huh.
...for the first time...
-Yes.
-...this episode.
And it was a little awkward
encounter.
How does Molly feel about, uh,
Condola and Issa's friendship?
Well I don't know
how Molly feels about Condola,
but I know how Molly feels
about Issa.
-Whoa.
-And she is trying
to protect her friendship.
And she just feels like,
as messy as Molly is,
she sees the messiness.
Like, this ain't gonna work.
But she's so nice.
They all are.
-It is that thing though...
-I mean,
it's always the nice ones
you gotta watch out for.
But you don't think
that there's any jealousy
rooted in Molly's interactions
with them,
in her POV of Condola?
Because...
Condola has been around a lot,
and has been occupying
a lot of Issa's time.
(STAMMERS)
Is Yvonne also jealous?
(LAUGHS)
Molly is not the jealous type,
but I ain't gonna front,
when we were shooting this
I was like, "Uh...
Why this ho still here?"
(ALL LAUGHING)
And it's also like this thing
where--
It's like when you know
your friend.
-YVONNE ORJI: Yes.
-And you're like,
"I know this is not
gonna end well."
(ALL LAUGHING)
"So why--"
I'm trying to help you--
-Let's fast forward the process.
-But you--" Yes.
So what do you think
is going through Issa's mind
when Lawrence tells her
that he likes Condola
and he wants it to work out
with her?
You know, I think that's when
it becomes kind of real.
It was real when Condola
dropped the news,
you know, last episode.
And I think here,
it's just like,
he's saying he likes her,
and he wants to--
He really wants
to make an effort
to not have anything cloud
-cloud her view of him.
-Yeah.
And I think it hits her
in a realization way,
but I don't think that she has
fully processed
what that means just yet.
The thing about Condola is
like she knows your weaknesses.
So in some way
it's like Lawrence, like,
got his life together
and they're great
and she's great
and it's like,
"I'm over here asking her
for help?"
ALL: Oof.
That's real. I'm done.
-Yvonne. Now, in this episode,
-Mm-hmm.
Andrew has a hard time
sort of opening up to Molly.
-He does.
-Why do you think that is?
I don't know if it's that
he is, like,
fear of commitment
but it's weird,
because he pushes in
as if, like,
-"I'm ready to commit."
-Yeah.
And then it's like
he pulls back.
So that's what's kind
of frustrating
and annoying to Molly,
because it's like,
"Are we in it, are we--"
It's like we're double dutching.
I also think too, I think
it's also a very guy thing
to like, in last season,
he was hunting her...
-Yes.
-...where it's like a chase.
It's like she's rebuffing me,
now I'm obsessed.
And then he kind of got her,
and then he was a little bit
like, "What you mean,
I gotta open up now?"
"I'm-- I'm just trying to fuck
and have fun with you a lot.
Like what's the problem?
Why we gotta talk?"
♪ Such is the problem
With dating ♪
(ALL LAUGHING)
So in the spirit
of this episode,
what do you do
when your best friend
is getting closer
to someone else?
Hmm. Well there's some people
I know in Nigeria
that I can call and like
make people disappear.
-So...
-(LAUGHS)
So you kill them?
Murder is your answer?
-(CHUCKLES) I said disappear.
-Oh.
I watch Investigation Discovery,
there's a big difference.
-You know this is on camera.
-What?
-Okay.
-(BOTH LAUGHING)
Uh, I'm a dude. Dudes don't
really get like all--
-I'm trying to think of a time--
-ORJI: Are you sure?
I don't think I've ever
been mad like--
If a dude that you don't like
is coming around--
Yes, that is annoying.
Like if Condola was like,
actually real annoying
and real disruptive,
like I had a buddy of mine
that would always bring--
We'd go to Vegas
and he'd always invite
eight other people.
And I'm just like, "Bro..."
-Oof.
-That's not it.
That's not it.
Yeah, for me,
I have blended friend groups,
and that's all well and good
with me.
Just don't leave me out.
(ALL LAUGHING)
-If you start leaving me out...
-Yes.
-Now we have a problem.
-...we have a problem.
I think just watching you
and your friendships,
you've been really good
at making everybody feel...
connected.
Like you're loyal.
Like your loyalty and friendship
is very admirable.
Until they leave me out
of some shit, and then...
They gon' learn. (CHUCKLES)
-Okay.
-Hey.
Well thank you all so much
for Wining Down with us.
We can't wait to see you again
next week.
Cheers.
-I mean I'm gonna drink.
-Yeah.
I mean we usually get drinks.
(ALL LAUGHING)
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪